missouri congresswoman cory bush has
some interesting ideas about the cops
and the mass coveted hysteria continues
from democrats despite indicators that
the florida wave may begin to wane very
very soon i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
the bench bureau show is sponsored by
expressvpn don't let big tech track what
you do anonymize your web browsing at
expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first here is your reminder
you are paying way too much on your cell
phone bill right now if you've got atd
or t-mobile or verizon you just are
instead you need to switch over to pure
talk usa like thousands of my wise
listeners already have puretalk can save
your family over 800 a year it's the
same great coverage because pure talk is
on the exact same network as one of the
big three but at a fraction of the price
and switching is as easy as switching
out your sim card you can keep your
phone keep your number or get huge
discounts on the latest iphones and
androids plus right now you can get
unlimited talk text and six gigs of data
for just 30 bucks a month and if you go
over on the data they're not going to
charge you for it at all if there's a
reason pure talk is the highest rated
wireless company by consumer affairs why
they are the preferred wireless partner
of amac so how can you access this
excellent service easy from your cell
phone dalpound250 say ben shapiro save
an additional 50 off your very first
month that is pound 250 say my name ben
shapiro to get started switch over to
puretalk usa you could be saving
yourself hundreds of dollars a year and
save an additional 50 off your very
first month dial pound 250 save ben
shapiro to get started with my friends
over at pure talk usa alrighty so
the left seems to be in a war with
itself right now and i'm very much
rooting for the moderate left to win i
want moderate liberals to win the battle
against the woke and it seems like this
is happening in terms of electoral
politics but oddly enough it's not
happening in terms of policy and that's
really quite strange because the reality
is that inside the democratic party
there are many many more people who are
sort of moderate than the there are
people who have heavy sympathies for the
woke now in elite circles it's precisely
the reverse in elite circles in the
media particularly in the halls of power
in institutions there's a lot of
sympathy for the woke there are a lot of
people out there who who think of the
woke as sort of the most dedicated to
the cause and so they're willing to give
them all sorts of slack they're willing
to allow them all sorts of room to run
they're willing to defend them even when
they say overtly stupid and bizarre
things they're willing to follow their
policy lead but the democratic party
base is not aligned with this they just
are not
the latest indicator of that this week
was this race in ohio between chantal
brown a democratic count county
councilor fighting against nina turner
who's a former co-chair for bernie
sanders presidential campaign in the
15th congressional district which is a
safely republican seat around columbus
energy industry lobbyist mike carey
meanwhile pervado prevailed over a
crowded field boosted by former
president donald trump's endorsements
there are a couple of uh open primaries
the other night and um they're kind of
mixed results on the gop side but the
big result on the democratic side was of
course that there was this big infight
that went on between nina turner who
again was that former co-chair for
bernie and chantal brown so it looked
like nina turner was going to win that
safe democratic seat and then the entire
democratic party infrastructure said
wait we don't need another member of the
squad we need somebody who's more
aligned with the sort of biden rhetoric
who's more aligned with the middle of
the democratic party and so you saw
james clyburn intervene in exactly the
same way he did in the presidential race
and then it turned out that nina turner
got pretty much skunked by chantel brown
now this was a rejection of the squad
make no mistake about this
representative alexander ocasio-cortez
had told voters during a july swing
through the district to vote for nina
turner said please send me nina brown 45
had entered the race with local clout
turner had name recognition from a
career in ohio politics and the two
campaigns with sanders but brown turned
the campaign into a referendum on
president biden reminding voters that
turner had criticized him and cast a
protest vote against the 2020 democratic
platform brown was ahead of turner by
six points when the race was officially
called
in a concession speech turner said the
country had been through a desert of
despair indifference inequality and
racism tonight my friends we've looked
across the promised land but for this
campaign on this night we will not cross
the river again the moderate candidate
caught up to the radical candidate after
james clyburn endorsed her and after the
democratic majority for israel's pac ran
ads warning that turner could undermine
the democratic agenda
brown's campaign emphasized support for
biden and said that turner was simply
too radical and thus turner went down to
flaming defeat and yet strangely enough
again in elite circles there seems to be
more sympathy for the bernie sanders
wing of the party than for the
traditional sort of joe biden wing of
the party which is why it's been very
weird to watch the continued fealty to
cory bush so cory bush is this radical
missouri congress person she got her
start being a black lives matter
activist and then she's become this very
loud adjunct member of the squad she's
the second wave member of the squad the
squad existed and then she was recently
elected to congress was corey bush and
of course she made headlines this week
when she camped out on the steps of the
capitol building to protest evictions
and then the biden administration
announced that in defiance of the
constitution of the united states joe
biden would simply declare an eviction
moratorium even if it would be struck
down by the supreme court itself and
here's the thing why would you follow
corey bush down this primrose path at
all cory bush is terrible her policies
are not in line with what the vast
majority of americans want the entire
democratic party has spent the last few
months attempting for example to run
ahead long away from the defund the
police sloganeering of people like corey
bush and aoc and nohan omar and rashida
talib and yet when it comes to much of
their policy they seem to be following
the lead of the squad and every so often
corey bush will just leroy jenkins it
right every so often the democratic
probably like guys we really we don't
need to do this defund the police stuff
because it's really it pulls really bad
you know let's do let's do this policy
stuff in the dead of night when not a
lot of people are watching but let's not
campaign as overtly radical let's not do
that and then corey bush will be like
leeroy jenkins and just rush in you know
face first so that's what happened
yesterday corey bush was doing an
interview and she declared that she
wanted to defund the police but she
didn't just say that she said i pay for
security i have taxpayer-funded security
i need security but you the regular
people you don't need police we should
defund the police
i'm going to make sure i have security
because i know i have had attempts on my
life and i have too much work to do
there are too many people that need help
right now for me to allow that so if i
end up spending 200 000 if i spend 10 10
10 more dollars on it you know what i
get to be here to do the work so suck it
up and defunding the police has to
happen we need to defund the police and
put that money into social safety nets
because we're trying to save lives
so in the exact same sentence where she
says that she deserves two hundred
thousand 000 of security
she says that you should not have
security
why are the democrats following this and
here's the thing i think the reason that
the democrats have decided that they're
going to treat the squad and the radical
left of their own party with respect is
not really for electoral benefit so much
as it is about the belief by the
democrats that anytime somebody on the
right has a critique the critique has to
be false there's a really interesting
piece today over at a a sub stat called
the liberal patriot by a guy named roy
teshera now roy teshera is a major
democrat and roy teshera is one of the
people who used to write essays about
the browning of america and how
demographic change was eventually going
to lead to this magical democratic
utopia well now he is warning that
democrats are completely disconnected
from reality that they have fallen into
what he calls the fox news fallacy
here's what he says he says the fox news
fallacy is having a dire effect on many
democrats this is the idea that a fox
news substitute here the conservative
bet noir of your choice if you prefer
criticizes the democrats for x there
must be absolutely nothing to x and the
job of democrats is to assert that
loudly and often the problem is that an
issue is not necessarily completely
invalid just because fox news mentions
it that depends on the issue if there's
something to the issue and persuadable
voters have real concerns you will not
allay those concerns by embracing the
fox news fallacy in fact you'll probably
intensify them by giving such voters the
impression that democrats simply don't
care about their concerns and will do
nothing to address them that will
undermine the democrats ability to
respond to predictable attacks against
their candidates in 2022 and raise the
likelihood of a midterm debacle
and he cites a few examples of this one
of them is crime he points out that a
lot of people on the right have been
pointing out the rising crime rates in
major cities around the united states
and yet democrats continue to proclaim
over and over and over again that there
really is no big crime problem
that the crime problem is all just made
up by the fox news crowd and this is not
going to redound to the democrats
benefit
another example of what roy teshera
calls the fox news fallacy is the
immigration issue he says the biden
administration has resisted and still
resists calling the situation at the
mexican border a crisis and initially
insisted that the surge at the border
would go away on its own as the hot
weather season arrived this was the line
most democrats adhered to invoking the
idea the issue was more a fox news
talking point than a real problem it's
now apparent the border search is not
going away any time soon and that the
perceived liberalization of the border
regime under the biden administration
has indeed spurred more migrants to try
their luck at the border and it's not
going away with the hot weather the
washington post reports officials have
made more than one million apprehensions
at the southwest border this fiscal year
as of june 210 000 more individuals
probably crossed in july this is the
highest monthly encounter number since
fiscal year 2000.
and there's a reason why joe biden's
approval rating on immigration is now at
30 37
up 52
down
he is only at 30 approval rating among
independents by the way and critical
race theory is another issue where
democrats are completely missing the
boat because republicans mention it
democrats have decided that this is no
longer worth concerning themselves over
there's almost a sort of
bizarre
it's it's like a bizarre
reverse psychology effect here that
democrats are falling prey to the minute
that republicans say something is a
problem democrats immediately declare
that not only is it not a problem it's
something good so if we say that the
squad is completely radical and
proposing policies that are ridiculous
on their face the democrats say that
we're making it up
and then the american people know we're
not making it up because they have eyes
they have ears they can see it happening
by the way this also happens in reverse
right this is not unique to the to the
left the right the right has this as
well if the left makes a criticism of
the right that has some legitimacy to it
very often people on the right will just
go well if the left is saying it must be
false well no it might be false but that
doesn't mean it definitely is false
right now for the biden administration
however they are falling into a real
political trap here because they are so
attached to the idea that fox news is
the font of all evil and shows like this
one are not worth listening to and that
anyone who disagrees with them is a
vicious bigot they're so attached to
that idea that they are disregarding the
fact that many many americans agree that
their agenda has skewed far too radical
and as roy to share points out this is
certainly true with regard to critical
race theory
right the the american people do not
like critical race theory
the the polling data shows this stuff is
really really unpopular it's unpopular
in virginia
and roy teshera concludes democrats who
embrace the fox news fallacy are
inclined to believe there is no real
issue here other than voters whipped up
by fox news or simply opposed to
teaching students about slavery and the
like that is a mistake and blinds
democrats to a real problem that is
emerging generally democrats need to
wean themselves away from the fox news
fallacy as a generic response to
conservative attacks this is exactly
correct but democrats don't seem to be
getting the message
not with regard to the cory bush wing of
the democratic party and now with regard
to covet either because it turns out
that a lot of the critiques from the
right are steeped not in anti-vaxxerism
they are steeped in data they are
steeped in science they're pointing out
that there is a serious lack of data for
much of what the left is calling for
right now
and because the left doesn't like the
right they're just ignoring it and
they're pretending that they can dismiss
all of that with the wave of a hand and
everybody will just accept it this is a
bad political move for them i mean
honestly if they want to do it go for it
it's just going to make a lot of lives
worse and then they're just going to get
the ass kicking they deserve come 2022.
we'll get to more of this in just one
second first let us talk about your
sleep quality okay so as you can tell i
am not broadcasting from home that means
that my sleep quality has been garbage
lately okay that's because i am missing
my helix sleep mattress i need my helix
sleep mattress it is made just for me it
is personalized to this unbelievably
apollo-esque body helix sleep has a quiz
it takes just two minutes to complete
matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you why would you buy a mattress made
for someone else with helix you're
getting a mattress you know will be
perfect for the way you sleep
everybody's unique helix knows that they
have several different mattress models
to choose from they have soft medium and
firm mattresses mattresses great for
cooling you down if you sleep hot even a
helix plus mattress for plus size folks
so if you're looking for a mattress you
take the quiz you order the mattress
that you're matched to the mattress
comes right to your door shipped for
free you don't ever need to go to a
mattress store again helix is awesome
you don't need to take my word for it
helix was awarded the number one best
overall mattress pick of 2020 by both gq
and wired magazine just head on over to
helixsleep.com take their two minute
sleep quiz they will match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life they've got
a 10-year warranty you get to try it out
for 100 nights risk-free they'll even
pick it up for you if you don't love it
but you will helix is offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners right now at
helixsleep.com go check them out right
now helix sleep.com
ben okay so the democrats are not just
following for the fox news fallacy as
roy tashara puts it when it comes to
defunding the police or when it comes to
crt or when it comes to immigration
they're falling for it when it comes to
covid
so this morning nate silver of 538 the
sort of pollster extraordinaire he put
out this really sort of fascinating
analysis of where the american public
falls on coveted restrictions
and here is here's what he says and it's
worthy of exploring because i basically
agree with this analysis he says that
there are essentially five groups in
american life when it comes to these
coveted lockdowns group a he says about
25 of the electorate this would be like
the hard left this is vaccinated but not
ready for a return to normal and thinks
society has opened up too fast they're
very worried about delta in favor of any
and all restrictions including lockdowns
and remote learning some of this group
will transition into group b when and if
cases start falling okay group b is the
biggest single group it's about 30
these are the vaccinated somewhat
worried about delta in favor of modest
restrictions like indoor masking
especially if they target the
unvaccinated at the same time they don't
want to return to lockdowns although
some could drift into group a like they
could be more hard on lockdowns if cases
keep rising or if there are scary new
variants this is quickly becoming the
consensus position among
college-educated elites okay then
there's group c
about 15 of the population this is the
vaccinated but over the pandemic
population and wary of restrictions
likely a mix of younger voters who don't
vote at high rates and some center-right
libertarian types okay i fall under this
category right i am group c i'm
vaccinated i'm over the pandemic i
believe the science does not support
continued lockdowns not only do i think
that it doesn't support continued
lockdowns i think that as a public
policy matter we are now done
you know who agrees with me would be dr
marty mccary of johns hopkins university
he has an excellent piece over at u.s
news and world report today
he points out
that as a physician with a lot of
experience dealing with patients who
don't follow what we ask them to do i
believe you win more bees with honey
than fire he says the vaccines are so
good at protecting against death from
coca-19 those who are immune can feel
good about living life without having to
worry about becoming severely ill
vaccines downgrade the infection to a
mild seasonal virus one we must learn to
live with for years to come those who
choose not to get vaccinated are making
a poor health decision at their own
individual risk again this is dr marti
mccary they pose no public health threat
to those already immune would we be so
stern toward people making similar or
worse health choices to smoke drink
alcohol or not wear a helmet when riding
a bike over 85 000 americans die
annually from alcohol and we don't have
the same public health fervor or
requirements to save those lives let's
encourage vaccination rather than
activate the personal liberty culture
wars that result in people becoming more
entrenched in their opposition also says
mccary the notion we have to vaccinate
every living walking american and
eventually every newborn in order to
control the pandemic is based on the
false assumption that the risk of dying
from coven 19 is equally distributed in
the population it's not we've always
known that it's very hard for the virus
to hurt someone who is young and healthy
that's still the case while vaccine
requirements for healthcare workers make
sense we would never extend those
requirements outside of healthcare for
say the flu shot we'd simply say to the
public those who avoid the flu shot do
so at their own risk okay this is the
rational decision okay the rational
decision here is to be part of what nate
silver terms group c right to get
vaccinated and then you're done and if
someone else chooses not to get
vaccinated it is no longer your business
because you are now immune to dying from
the virus on any baseline statistical
level okay and then there is group d
this is 25 of the population
unvaccinated and strongly opposed to any
restrictions
right so that would be a lot of the
trump rural voters for example right who
are like listen i was never that worried
about the virus or i'm young and healthy
i'm still not worried about the virus
and i'm not asking anything of you by
the way the vast majority of people who
are unvaccinated fall into group d
and finally group e the fifth group
nate silver again this is his breakdown
he said that's about five percent of the
population he says those are people who
are unvaccinated but in favor of other
restrictions indeed they may think such
restrictions are necessary to protect
them because they can't or won't get
vaccinated this group probably leans
democratic and working class
right so presumably that would be
minority voters in major american cities
maybe maybe okay so
here is the important part about this
breakdown what this breakdown suggests
is that about 70
of the american population
of the american population is against
lockdowns
right the biggest group is vaccinated
and they're a little worried about delta
but not super worried about delta and if
they were actually given the information
about how not dangerous delta is to them
as the vaccinated they would be
significantly less worried about delta
they keep getting scared by the media
into a belief that there's a variant
right around the corner that is going to
break through the vaccines at any moment
by the way if there is we cannot do
anything to stop that in the united
states we can't the delta variant
started in india before that there was
the brazil variant you'll recall you'll
recall that this original virus started
in wuhan
there are literally hundreds of millions
of people who have this virus or have
had this virus or who will get this
virus all there has to be is one group
of people somewhere on earth who are not
vaccinated in order for there to be a
new variant possibility okay so what
does that mean i mean 70 of the american
population which is an overwhelming
majority of americans are at least
skeptical of lockdown policies and mass
mandates and all the rest of this stuff
and that group group b
which is sort of they're vaccinated but
they tend toward the cautious
if they really understood the stats they
really would not be in group b they
would be in group c
right they would be vaccinated and they
would be over it because that is the
rational position as a vaccinated person
it is significantly less rational as a
vaccinated person to be seriously
worried about delta
if you're a vaccinated person you should
not be seriously worried about delta in
terms of your own personal risk level
and by the way in terms of the risk
level to your children because the stats
on children being directly harmed by
delta are very very skimpy
very skimpy remember under 350 kids
under the age of 18 in the united states
in the united states have died of covet
period in the entire united states
by the way if you go to like the age of
30 that's still only an additional 2 500
people
those sub-populations are well in excess
of 100 million people in the united
states
okay so that means that 75 70 of the
population is just not in favor of these
sorts of lockdowns and mass mandates or
anything like that but because the right
is saying that the left feels the need
to ignore that 70 of the population or
try to scare group b the vaccinated who
are somewhat cautious into being group a
vaccinated who want to lock down which
is the least
understandable of any of these groups i
mean that position makes no sense
vaccinated people who want lockdowns are
just
out of touch with reality at this point
they don't care about the science
they're not interested in the science
but it seems like our public health
establishment are so angry
at so much of the american population
for being over it that they're just
gonna continue to try and scare people
they're falling into the fox news
fallacy just because people like me
are on the right and people like me i've
been encouraging vaccinations since day
one people like rhonda sansa's desantis
one just because there are a lot of
people on the right who are pro-vaccine
and also believe that the vaccine frees
you up for life and that if you're a
responsible adult you now get to make a
decision the left has decided that they
are going to go full lockdown
okay this is why you have this heavy
pressure campaign being brought with
regard to the unvaccinated right so
anthony fauci the great and saint dr
anthony fauci he spent today ripping the
unvaccinated and suggesting that they
are going to be responsible for a brand
new variant of delta uh and and that
this is going to kill everybody
this is not effective it's not
you know what honestly you start to see
some upticks in the number of people who
are getting vaccinated you know why
because people are assessing their
personal risk factors and deciding that
perhaps they ought to get vaccinated not
because they're getting shouted at by dr
anthony fauci but because people do risk
mitigation it's how humanity has
survived for several hundred thousand
years
here's anthony fauci going hard after
the unvaxxed anyway
my concern would be you may allow
a variant that we haven't even
recognized yet to come along and in fact
be better at transmitting
and more serious than the delta we
haven't seen that yet so rather than be
worrying about these others that are
around let's make sure we don't let new
ones come in
well are unvaccinated people the reason
we're seeing these new strains and will
an increase in vaccinations mitigate the
virus morphine in multiple ways
uh well that's a good one because the
answer is short yes
okay except for the fact that no matter
how many vaccines you trench out in the
united states there's still going to be
variants other places on earth zero
covet is not a realistic goal fauci
knows this he's not saying that because
that would suggest that we have
basically reached the end of what we can
do in terms of public policy and he
doesn't want to let go of it he just
does not want to let go of it by the way
you're seeing companies start to mirror
that group a
you know that that group a sort of
mentality vaccinated but still in favor
of lockdown amazon says it's now going
to delay corporate employees returning
to offices until next year next year
which is just madness at this point and
the average amazon employee is probably
25 years old the point here is that for
the left one of the reasons this has
become political is because it's just
reactionary so
there's more and more of a push like day
in and day out more and more of a push
to lock people down mask people up
this is not borne out by reality okay
right now there's this continued focus
for example on florida you've noticed
okay and this this continued focus on
florida is largely because joe biden is
very much afraid of governor ron
desantis in florida who's a popular
governor of florida the media every so
often decided to focus in on a surge in
florida they never focus on the overall
death stats because if they did they
would realize that florida would be
second oldest population in america
really the oldest because they're a very
large state with a lot of old people
florida currently ranks 26th in the
death per million rate as opposed to new
york and new jersey which ranked
respectively two and one in the death
per million rate so instead every time
there's a florida surge the media cover
it and then they yell at rhonda sanchez
a lot and joe biden jumped in on that
his suggestion of course is that if if
there were just mass mandates in florida
that would kill the spread okay there's
only one problem there is no proof that
mass mandates have done this anywhere
there is no proof that mass mandates are
effective that doesn't mean masks aren't
effective masks may be effective in
certain circumstances although the
reality is delta because it's so
transmissible there are serious
questions about whether masking is even
super effective with regard to this i'm
not saying that professor william
hazeltine formerly of harvard medical
school is saying that he's saying
delta's going right through surgical
masks for example
another question you should ask when
people come into your house to or
workmen come in
are you vaccinated and will you wear
your mask please
i think that's another really important
question for personal safety please wear
your mask and hopefully it's an n95 mask
because delta has the propensity to go
through some of the uh
surgical masks for example it's not as
good protection as it used to be you're
spewing out a thousand times more virus
than you did before and so you need a
tougher mass okay by the way
there's not a single child in america
right when they're talking about kids
wearing masks in schools kids are not
wearing n95s kids are wearing cloth
masks i know my kids wore cloth masks
all of last year they worked at summer
camp this year as well because the camp
they went to was hyperactive about this
sort of stuff okay but joe biden is
targeting ron desantis over there so you
remember a couple of days ago he ripped
a sansas to sansa's push back on him
well now joe biden forgot who ron
desantis is now
i'm just going to play this clip
i think there's at least a 50 50 shot
that joe biden is being honest and he
literally does not remember who ron
desantis is and that's not because he
doesn't know who desantis is it's
because joe biden is not with us and has
not been with us for quite some time
here's the president of the united
states
who is using your words about don't be
in the way and he's saying i am in the
way to block too much interference from
the federal government your response mr
president governor who desantis
governor
oh the guy that you were targeting you
know from the white house joe biden has
been losing that exchange and so he has
to do governor who but again this is a
case where the left refuses to
acknowledge the realities on the ground
one of those realities is that the r
rate in florida is apparently waning the
r rate is the reproduction rate of the
particular virus okay when there's
massive spread that means that people
are spreading it to more and more people
okay already it seems as though florida
is now on the downslope of that now that
doesn't mean that infections are on the
downslope in florida it means that
infections in the next couple of weeks
are likely to start declining and
declining pretty markedly as they have
in a wide variety of other countries
already in fact florida's florida
healthcare ceos they're already saying
like despite the media coverage that
florida hospitals are completely
overwhelmed there's no room people are
dying in the aisles okay that's not true
here here at florida healthcare ceos
yesterday talking about how yes of
course they're busier with covet they're
seeing more cases but they still have
capacity
our icus last time around we're running
40 of our inpatients right now we're
down to 25 of our inpatients in icus
other hospitals in south florida are
seeing even less numbers than that
between 15 and 20 percent of their
patient icu well ron desantis points
this out as well he says the media is
spreading misinformation about florida
being overwhelmed he says florida is not
actually overwhelmed at this point that
doesn't mean that florida hasn't had to
shift capacity but this is not like it
was back during january where the
hospitals were actually in danger of
being you know sort of in overflow
territory
we've had seen significant increases in
covet patients but as the ceo of tampa
general said that's 10 to 15 percent of
their total census and it's important
when the media is spreading this
misinformation and actually lying
it could deter someone from going in to
get care for things like heart problems
or stroke and so all those ceos said we
are treating everybody we're open for
business you know we're busier with
covid than we were six weeks ago but
please come in and get care okay the
point here is that when it comes to the
so-called fox news fallacy being
described by roy to share when it comes
to covid it's the desantis fallacy
whatever desantis says must be treated
by the media as though it is completely
outrageous even though a huge majority
of americans kind of agree with it again
if you take a look at that nate silver
breakdown again you will see that 70 of
americans are pretty skeptical of a lot
of the measures that are being
recommended and if that 30 of people who
are like in favor of some mild measures
particularly for the unvaccinated if
they actually knew about their own risk
factors i have a feeling a lot of those
people would be in my category of
vaccinated i'm done
okay but the left can't let go of it
because desantis is bad and so you have
cnn's national security analyst for
example telling the unvaccinated that we
should actually stop them from flying at
this point
one of one of the
the cnn security analysts he said
there's no such thing as a federal
mandate but the federal government can
use carrots and sticks and privileges
and burdens one of the areas where it
can do that is on airline travel because
the us government sets the rules and
conditions for it here's the thing about
airline travel airline travel has been
pretty damn safe since the beginning of
the pandemic okay there there have been
no data linking airline traffic people
getting coveted on planes okay that is
not so far as we are aware a main vector
of transmission
there have been multiple studies done on
this one of the reasons is because
planes have excellent hepa filters
they're they're filtering the entire air
of the plane like every three or four
minutes
so
the the notion that we have to shut down
air travel for the unvaccinated is
really kind of silly and particularly if
you're doing that on behalf of the
vaccinated which is really silly
also you have people like again the
desantis effect here the department of
education head miguel cardona saying
that it's because of desantis that
schools might shut down in florida are
you kidding desantis is the only one who
kept schools open you guys shut down all
the schools last year for no damned
reason you shut them down in california
the entire year you shut them down in
new york for the entire year you
educated every kid from home educated in
scare quotes in washington dc for like
the entire year and as ron desantis
who's going to shut down education you
literally had the cdc writing school
reopening guidelines along with the
american federation of teachers and
putting in a bunch of anti-scientific
nonsense and blather skype about social
distancing small children and having
them use plexiglass
and it's rhonda sanchez is going to shut
i mean the gas lighting here is really
extraordinary here's the departures the
department of education had miguel
cardona going after desantis
don't be the reason why schools are
interrupted
our kids have suffered enough
let's do what we know works
let's do what we know works across the
country
we shouldn't
get power politics doesn't have a role
in this
politics doesn't have a role in this
really doesn't it you literally wrote
the cdc guidance with help from people
who want to continue to shut down the
schools
that a stance in fact it's just the fox
news effect that's all this is that's
all it is
and it's getting even worse now that
democrats have decided they're going to
full skill embrace vaccine passports in
fact msnbc's stephanie rule objective
journalism getting that hot sticky
journalism all over the place she says i
don't even understand the argument
against vaccine passports don't you
though
like i can explain it really really
quickly to you it turns out that if you
tell everybody who's vaccinated they get
to go all the special places and
everybody else who's unvaccinated has to
hang out together you're gonna get a
faster spread
did you do you understand
i did it in small words in short
sentences
so that you could understand here's
stephanie rule saying she literally
doesn't understand why a vaccine
passport is a bad idea by the way israel
has been doing vaccine passports again
and israel is um is now going to full
lockdown probably at the beginning of
the holidays in september here is a
stephanie rule
and i don't understand those who are
against showing proof of vaccine have
they never had to show their passport
show their id or take their kids to
school it makes no sense to me oh my god
these are the exact same people who say
that it's racism to make you show your
id to vote
so let's just get this straight it's
racism to make you show your id to vote
because black people apparently are
incapable of getting a voter id but it's
not racism to make people show their
vaccine card if they are unvaccinated
disproportionately black people are
unvaccinated in this country
particularly in major cities
you'll notice that there is a heavy
crossover between black population in
the united states and unvaccinated areas
there are two large groups of people in
the us who are not getting vaccinated at
the same rates as everybody else one is
rural conservatives and the other is
inner city minorities those are the two
unvaccinated groups in the united states
unvaccinated for wildly variant reasons
except that there's a common distrust of
the government i think that that runs
through both
pretty astonishing stuff meanwhile
biden's coveted advisor jeffrey zens he
says that yelp is now going to let
businesses list their vaccination
policies
this is i've said before i think this is
a predicate to what comes next which is
this sort of social credit system where
businesses are going to start basically
carding you for a wide variety of social
sins this is just the beginning
businesses know vaccinations are a way
to keep their workers and customers safe
and to keep their op doors open
and today yelp is announcing a new
feature that allows consumers to search
for businesses
with fully vaccinated workers workers or
businesses that require proof of
vaccination to enter the business
again so much of this is just being
driven by if republicans oppose it it
must be good the the ultimate example of
this was msnbc's chris hayes this was
pretty hilarious the other day chris
hayes attacked marco rubio for
supposedly not pushing vaccines uh
there's only one problem with that which
is that he literally quoted marco rubio
pushing vaccines so marco rubio tweeted
out quote
stop with the mask fetish if you want to
wear a mask as a courtesy to those
around you or because you're in no mood
to get even a little sick go ahead if
you want your kids to mask in schools
that's right but we aren't going to mask
your way out of this
right and um and then he concluded that
people should actually vaccinate
right he he finished by suggesting
openly he says we're not going to mask
your way out of this and then he put up
like an actual verbal statement in which
he said at the very end that you should
mask quote the answer here is not masks
as i said you're not going to mask your
way out of this the answer here is
vaccines get vaccinated that's the
answer
chris hayes naturally tweeted this is a
really perfect example of the constant
triangulating cowardice and whatabadism
that's infected the entire party and
movement he can't just say hey get
vaccinated have to find some way to own
the libs
uh no chris i i have a feeling you're
missing a mirror in your home um he
literally says get vaccinated but you
have to find a way to triangulate so as
to blame republicans for people not
getting vaccinated even when republicans
are telling people to get vaccinated
okay guys if you want to keep going with
the fox news fallacy all you or the
desantis fallacy whatever you choose to
call it enjoy yourselves because it is
not going to down to your benefit
alrighty in just one second we'll get to
the latest on andrew cuomo is he will he
stay or will he go
i don't know we'll get to that in one
second first let us talk about the fact
that if you want to sleep well you need
product from my pillow you guys hear me
talk every week about how much i love
the my pillow products well now my
pillow is changing the game with their
six-piece towel set too this set is made
with usa cotton making it extremely
absorbent it's still providing that soft
feel you look for in a towel the set
comes with two bath two hand towels and
two washcloths typically retailing for
109.99 for a limited time you get all
that stuff the two bath two hand towels
two washcloths for 39.99 that's 60
percent in savings always remember all
my pillow products come with a 60-day
money-back guarantee so you've got
nothing to lose i promise you once you
try these towels you're going to want to
keep them they come in a variety of
colors and sizes they're the best towels
i have used in years they are indeed
fabulous you've heard me talk about my
pillows amazing pillows and sheets well
now they've got the perfect towels as
well go to mypillow.com click on the
radio listener square use promo code
daily wire at checkout or call
800-651-1148 you'll receive this amazing
six-piece towel set for just 39.99
that's mypillow.com click on the radio
listener square use promo code dailywire
call
1-800-651-1148 use promo code dailywire
go to mypillow.com and make sure you use
that promo code dailywire already in
just one second we'll get to the latest
on andrew cuomo
killing old people and uh and
grabbing people's asses but he's all out
old people we'll get to that in just one
second first i have some bad news and i
have some good news for you the bad news
is our own president is now playing
authoritarian dictator while
circumventing us law to extend the
eviction moratorium and admitting that
he is doing so unconstitutionally the
good news is i wrote a book about this
so if you actually want to know what
exactly is going on in this
authoritarian moment go pick up my book
the authoritarian moment it now clocked
in at number two on the publisher's
weekly bestseller list number three on
the new york times bestseller list
authoritarianism is here it is here not
just in the form of some government
policy it is here in every institution
you feel it you feel it in your daily
life the authoritarian moment is hell
the institutions you deal with on a
daily basis have been taken over by the
woke and more importantly how you resist
it head on over to amazon barnes and
noble or any other major bookseller get
your copy right now the authoritarian
moment leave a five star review help get
my book to number one on that new york
times best seller list it is very very
appreciated also as the president begins
to turn his back on the citizens of the
country he swore to protect there is no
time more important to talk about the
current state of the world politically
culturally philosophically over cigars
and whiskey for the world to watch and
because we are so appreciative of
everyone who tunes in to watch daily
wire backstage we're getting you in on
the action we are giving away a trip for
two to come hang with us your favorite
daily wire host backstage here at our
national studio you can meet us all tour
the studios and offices get a great swag
bag of merch and watch us debate on the
show live you're gonna want to hurry
today is indeed your very last chance if
you're not a member yet head on over to
dailywire.com backstage enter code
backstage in at checkout for 25 off your
membership and get automatically entered
to win one of the coolest trips you will
ever take this is the last chance today
friday august 6th this is your last
chance come hang with us backstage head
on over to dailywire.com subscribe code
backstage get 25 off your membership and
a chance to win the ultimate backstage
experience right now also we have a
brand new show i know if you heard it's
called the morning wire it is fantastic
it's nothing but the facts it's been
topping apple and spotify since its
recent release it is the only daily news
podcast that values your time and the
truth we are working overtime to bring
you the news you need to know but we
need your help to keep the facts
trending toward number one subscribe now
to morningwire on apple spotify or
wherever you listen to podcasts leave a
five star review if you like what you
hear it is brought to you by daily wire
editor and chief john bickley and
co-host georgia howe morningwire will
wake you up with the latest developments
in politics sports culture and education
all with a heavy emphasis on the facts
in 15 bite size minutes perfect for your
daily commute so again subscribe to
morning wire on apple podcast spotify
and everywhere you listen to podcasts so
you don't miss a beat if you like what
you hear leave a five star view tell the
podcast platforms conservative news
belongs at number one on the charts
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
alrighty meanwhile the big question
regarding andrew cuomo is whether he
will stay or whether he will go so
that's up to the legislature at this
point because he ain't going nowhere i
mean there is no way he is going to quit
there is no political upside to quitting
in american politics anymore that
started with bill clinton there is now
no standard as to when a politician
should resign right when a politician is
caught
in flagrant
the typical history of that was that up
until the clinton people just quit bill
clinton did not quit he stuck around he
kind of
he kind of pulled his way forward
through it and he uh and he lived long
enough to become a hero again with the
democratic party base until the point
where he became inconvenient and then he
was kind of jettisoned and then he's
still brought back from time to time
when he is useful and from that
politicians learned a very simple thing
never resign right make them come and
get you and andrew cuomo is one of those
politicians and frankly i don't blame
him you'll recall that al franken the
senator from minnesota he resigned after
allegations that he was groping women
during photo shoots and like grabbing
their asses in the middle of photo lines
and all this sort of stuff and uh and he
resigned and the real reason that he
resigned was not because the democrats
had suddenly decided that ask rabbery
was a real problem the reason that he
resigned is because his resignation came
right in the middle of the roy moore
controversy in alabama and the idea that
the democrats were trying to push is
that democrats were really good at
policing their own in the metoo moment
but republicans were really bad at it
well as it turns out franken resigned
and then the republicans actually were
pretty good at policing the metoo moment
with roy moore he was nominated for the
senate and then he lost and now there
was a a senator from alabama who was a
democrat right named doug jones
so it turns out that was a waste and
ever since al franken has been trying to
climb his way back into politics he says
now that he regrets having resigned in
the first place well the same thing
applies to andrew cuomo
well now it looks like the new york
state assembly is going to start its
impeachment investigation they announced
that on thursday according to fox news
dot com the assembly judiciary committee
had law firm davis poke and wardwell
conduct an independent inquiry and have
asked cuomo to provide any materials he
would like to submit on his own behalf
as the investigation comes to an end
the firm told cuomo quote we write to
inform you that the committee's
investigation is nearing completion and
the assembly will soon consider
potential articles of impeachment
against your client accordingly we
invite you to provide any additional
evidence or written submissions you
would like the committee to consider
before its work concludes the assembly
also stated its attorneys had issued a
subpoena to cuomo for materials related
to their investigation but that he
hadn't turned anything over as of yet
cuomo's senior advisor again into rich
as a party responded on thursday quote
the assembly has said it is doing a full
and thorough review of the complaints
and has offered the governor and his
team an opportunity to present facts and
their perspective the governor
appreciates the opportunity we will be
cooperating the judiciary committee for
the new york state assembly is set to
meet on monday once their investigation
is finished the 150 member assembly
would have to pass an impeachment
resolution with a simple majority of 76
votes for the matter to go to the state
senate for a trial right now there are
already 80 assembly members on record
expressing support for the impeachment
normally the trial would be heard by the
senators the seven judges on the new
york court of appeals and lieutenant
governor if the governor is the one
under impeachment the lieutenant
governor and president pro tem who is
currently the senate majority leader
andrea stewart cousins are excluded
because they're in the line of
succession two-thirds of the court is
needed to convict that would be 46 votes
to date there are 37 senators who have
gone on record supporting the
progression of the impeachment process
so this thing looks like it's sort of on
nice edge and prominent democrats who
don't like cuomo and here here's the
real thing no one likes cuomo right if
you were popular with his own party the
way that ralph northam was or even just
in fairfax and virginia he'd be fine the
problem is that andrew cuomo has spent
the last several years crapping all over
everyone in the democratic party and now
they're coming for their revenge
democratic representative kathleen rice
who's a representative on the federal
level she says it's time to get cuomo
out of there
the governor still has the same people
around him who pretty much aided and
abetted his behavior as the report uh
documents and so the faster we get
the governor out of office um and and
all of those who
worked for him and clean up the
executive chamber the better it's going
to be for people who just want to work
in government and work in public service
they shouldn't have to face going to a
hostile toxic work environment every day
just to do their jobs okay andrea
stewart cousins who new york senate
majority leader again she won't be
voting on this because she's in the line
of succession she says the cuomo should
resign because we can all see the
writing on the wall at this point
i think so many people who
are involved and we are watching it up
close and we know uh that this is not
going to end well uh this is why so many
people are saying to the governor step
aside resign
now okay so i have a question do we
really think the principal has broken
out here or do we think that it's just a
good time for democrats to jettison
cuomo they got what they wanted out of
him last year now he's no longer useful
to them and so now they're going to dump
his body by the side of the road now
there could be something good that
theoretically comes out of this maybe
there's a new standard maybe the new
standard is that there is willingness to
impeach people inside your own party
when there's a full-scale documented
investigation that demonstrates the
guilt on a particular charge and that's
what it requires because here's the
problem there's been this gray area for
a long time and biden illustrates it
right because there have been
allegations about joe biden from tara
reid and about him
literally sexually assaulting her and
those were not taken supremely seriously
there was never a massive investigation
but he could rest on on that right he
could say there was never a massive
investigation she said something i said
something that's pretty much it so i'm
not resigning
and nobody's really pressured him inside
the democratic party to get out of the
race kamala harris did briefly and then
of course she flipped and she just was
like i'll be his vice president now you
remember that okay so what is the new
standard well if the new standard is
that we go through the entire
investigative procedure and then we
impeach
and under the threat of impeachment
people quit
i don't think that's a horrible standard
and i think frankly maybe that should be
the new standard but if the standard is
just going to be that we discard
politicians when they're no longer
convenient then i'm about as cynical
about this as it's possible to be i do
not think that politicians have suddenly
grown spines and have suddenly decided
that they are in fact you know folks who
are who are trustworthy on matters of
morality
and meanwhile speaking of joe biden i
don't think it's any wonder that as joe
biden engages in the sort of desantis
fallacy and the fox news fallacy his
approval ratings continue to tank
according to john nolte
his fraudulency joe biden is doing a
terrible job even the far left fake
pollsters at quinnipia couldn't juice
their latest poll to lift him over 50
approval rating
quinnipiac
is wildly biased toward biden as nolte
points out in 2020 quinnipiac had biden
winning florida by five trump won by
three they had biden winning ohio by
four trump won by eight right so
quinnipiac is very pro-biden and even
they can't get biden over 50 over that
hump and meanwhile
the democrats know they are wedded to
joe biden because lurking in the
background is the deeply unlikable
terrible politician kamala harris in
fact it's so bad over at the democratic
party hq that they had basically an
emergency meeting
over the weekend to ask what can be done
about kamala harris
how do you solve a problem like kamala
they're all singing it
here is what axios reports quote a group
of the democratic party's most
influential women met for dinner at a
home in the nation's capital last month
to game out how to defend vp kamala
harris and her chief of staff tina
florinoy against a torrent of bad press
the host was kiki mclean democratic
public affairs expert former advisor to
both clinton her guests included harris
confidante minion moore two former dnc
officials donna brazil and leia daughtry
biden advisor and leader of his outside
group stephanie cutter former hillary
clinton spokeswoman and democratic
strategist adrian elrod and karen finney
and former obama white house
communications director jennifer
palmieri nobody at the vp's office was
at the dinner but harris is attuned to
her outside network of supporters
harris's office declined to comment on
the dinner
the dinner had an urgent purpose
according to axios the operatives spent
the dinner discussing how to fight back
against negative perceptions how to help
harris boost her national media footing
they're trying to figure out exactly how
they help harris but they're having some
problems
right one of these sources said many of
us lived through the clinton campaign
and want to help curb some of the gender
dynamics and press coverage it was like
we've seen this before it's subtle when
things aren't going well for a male
politician we ask very different
questions et cetera et cetera but bottom
line is democrats are scared bleepless
about the possibility of kamala harris
running in 2024 they are wedded for
better or worse to the old man the
problem is the old man is engaging in
that fox news fallacy he is engaging in
radical policy day in and day out he's
undercutting the only reason why
americans like him in the first place
namely that he was supposed to be a
house plant he is not being a house
plant and it is not going to end well
for him alrighty we'll be back here
later today with an additional hour of
content first you can't forget to end
your week by checking out the andrew
clavin show drew shows every friday he
has an exciting evening planned for you
head on over to dailywire.com 7 p.m
eastern 6 pm central tune in i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pavel
wydowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciovitz
audio is mixed by mike caromina her
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica crans the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
john bickley here daily wire editor in
chief wake up every morning with our new
show morning wire on today's episode the
political war over cobot escalates
universities roll out new vaccine
mandates and a new bill proposes a
universal basic income for americans
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire
you